[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه معي ليال اختيار استهلها بابرز
العنويه
الاحتباس الحراري بحلول عام 20 50
محمد بن سلمان يؤكد على مساعد السعوديه
للوصول الى الحياه الصفري في عام 2050
الدائره
العربيه ان الاتفاق النووي مع ايران باسا
معقدا بقمعاها للمحتاجين
الشتاء لقلب الموازين على الارض
من جنود التعبئه لجبهات القتال
وعاشيه الانتخابات في الولايات المتحده
اللماسكي يصيب التصويت لصالح الجمهوريين
ويدعو لتقاسم السلطه بين الحزبين
الرئيسيين
[موسيقى]
اعلن ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن
سلمان في كلمته عن مبادره الشرق الاوسط
الاخضر واعلن ان المملكه ستخصص اثنين
فاصله خمسه مليار دولار من اجل المبادره
خضراء بالشرق الاوسط على مدار السنوات
العاشره القادمه
وستستضيف مقرها الرئيسي مؤكدا في الوقت
ذاته على استهداف السعوديه الوصول الى
الحياد الصفري في عام 2005
تاكيد راح الزمن المملكه بجهوده للجهود
استلام استلام الدوليه
اعلن عن استضافه المملكه مقر الامانه
العامه لمبادى الشرق الاوسط الاخضر
وقرارها للسهام بمبلغ مليارين و500 مليون
دولار دعما لمشروعاتها مبادره وميزانيه
الامانه العامه على مدى عشر سنوات القادمه
الاحتباس الحراري بحلول عام 20 50 من خلال
نهج الاقتصاد الدائري الكربون من اوائل
الصناديق الثروه السياديه عالميا والاول
في المنطقه الشرق الاوسط في استهدافه وصول
الحياه الصفري بحلول عام 20 50 مما يعزز
دور الصندوق كلاعب الرئيسيه في دعم الجهود
العالميه في مواجهه التحديات المناخ
كما اكد ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد
بن سلمان على ان المملكه اطلقت اكثر من
278 مليون طن من ثاني اكسيد الكربون لخفض
الانبعاثات بحلول 2030 كما تسعى السعوديه
الى ان تمثل الطاقه المتجدده 50% من
الاستهلاك في عام 2030
مليون طن مكافئ ثاني اكسيد الكربون بحلول
20 30 من خلال تطبيق
حلول تقنيات الاقتصاد الدائري الكربون
مبادره الحلول والوقود النظيف من اجل
توفير الغذاء
كما قامت المملكه بتسريع اوتيله تطرير
وتبني التقنيات ومصادر الطاقه النظيفه
المتمثله باستخدام الطاقه المتجدده بهدف
اداره انبعاثات ومن موارد الهيدروكربونيه
وابراز هذه الخطوه
يمثل يتمثل في تتويج مزيج الطاقه المستخدم
في توليد الكهرباء في المملكه بحيث يتم
انتاج 50% من الكهرباء داخل المملكه
بالاعتماد على مصادر الطاقه متجدده بحلول
20 30
بدوره اعلن الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي عبر مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر
انها فرصه لتعزيز التعاون بين الدول
لتمويل مشاريع مواجهه تغير المناخ
فان مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر تمثل فرصه
ممتازه لتعزيز التعامل بين اعضائها من
الدول بهدف حشد المزيد من الاستثمارات
وتوفير اليات جديده للتمويل المبتكر لدعم
المشروعات التي تقوم بها دولنا لمواجهه
تغير المناخ بالتنسيق مع الست تمويل
العربيه والاقليبيه التي تطلع بدون مهم في
هذا الاطار
في مصر ايضا وقمه المناخ حتى الرئيس
الفرنسي لولايات المتحده والصين والدول
الغنيه الاخرى غير الاوروبيه على دفع
حصتها العادله لمساعده الدول اكثر فقرا
على التعامل مع تغير المناخ واضاف ماكرون
للنشاطه المناخ على هامشي قمه الامم
المتحده للمناخ في شرم الشيخ بمصر اننا
بحاجه الى ان تكثف الولايات المتحده
والصين جهودها فيما يتعلق بخفض الانبعاثات
والمساعدات الماليه مؤكدا على ان الدول
الاوروبيه هي الوحيده التي تدفع حصتها
بشكل عادل
من جهتها اعلنت الخارجيه البريطانيه ان
الوزير جيمس كليفرلي سيعلن خلال مؤتمر
الامم المتحده المعنى بتغير المناخ في مصر
عن استثمارات تزيد عن 100 مليون جنيه
استرليني اي ما يعادل 115 مليون دولار
لدعم الدول الناميه في مواجهه اثار تغير
المناخ واضافه الخارجيه البريطانيه ان
كليفر لي سي يوضح ايضا ان الازدهار طويل
الامد يعتمد على اتخاذ اجراءات بشان تغير
المناخ وزياده الاستثمار في الطاقه
المتجدده في العالم
دراسات وابحاث جديده تؤكد ارتفاع نسبه
المصابين بالحساسيه وازدياد المخاطر على
الصحه العامه نتيجه التغير المناخي
والتلوث البيئي في المتتابعه
[موسيقى]
من شرم الشيخ تنضم الينا عبير عطيفه مديره
الوحده الاقليميه للاعلام في برنامج
الغذاء العالمي عبر الهاتف استاذه عبير
يعني بالتوجه الثالث او بالمستوى الثالث
مما يبحث بهذه القمه موضوع التمويل
والبرامج برامج التحول بموضوع التمويل
خصوصا للدول الناميه ودول المنطقه كيف
يمكن ان تؤثر على الامن الغذائي العالمي
طبعا من اهم المحاور الموجوده في قمه
المناخ في هذا العام هو محور الامن
الغذائي هناك تاثير بصوره مباشره ما بين
التغيرات المناخيه وما بين انتاج العالم
من المواد الزراعيه وطبعا اكيد الكوارث
الطبيعيه التي يشهدها العالم مثل الجفاف
الفيضانات شهدنا فيضان باكستان همم
الجفافي المناطق المناطق كثيره في افريقيا
عمليه التمويل اا دائما هي همم متجهه الى
الى التعامل مع ازمه المناخ لكن يجب ان
يكون هناك ايضا تفكير في التعامل مع تكيس
همم المجتمعات على التعامل مع اثار الازمه
المناخيه وهذا الشيء مهم بان يطالب به في
هذه القمه يجب ان يكون هناك اكيد تركيز
على عمليه ااا ال ال يعني تفادي ازمه
المناخ لكن ايضا يجب ان يكون هناك في دعم
للمجتمعات الاكثر هشاشه وليست عمل معها
المستوى الثاني من ما بحث بهذه الازمه
ولكن ما اضيف السنه هو موضوع التعويضات
والخسائر خصوصا ان الدول الناميه هي التي
تتضرر اكثر هل تامرون بان يكون هناك تعويض
حقيقي عن كل هذه الكوارث التي ذكرتيها
اكيد طبعا هناك همم امال كبيره على ان
يكون هناك دعم في عمليه التعويض ليه همم
الدول الاكثر الصوره وعلى الاخص ان معظم
هذه الدول هي الدول الاكثر هشاشه والاكثر
ضعفا والاكثر تاثرا بالادوات بالازمات
المناخيه بالرغم انها لم يكن لها دور كبير
او نسبه كبيره في همم العوامل التي ادت
الى الوضع الذي نشهده الان من تغيرات
المنى في الانبعاثات التي يعني كانت
بالنسبه كبيره وليس من هذه الدول اذا نحن
نتحدث عن اربع مستويات اي من هذه
المستويات اليوم تواجه مشكله حقيقه في
موضوع الطرح ويقطع التعويض
هو طبعا بالنسبه لكثير الدول الافريقيه
دوله مثل الباكستان الدول الكثير من الدول
الموجوده في منطقه الشرق الاوسط هي الدول
التي يعني محتاجه ان تستفيد من عمليه
التعويضات لكن على على اي حال بالنسبه
لملف برنامج الاغذيه العالمي ما يهمنا في
هذه المرحله هي عمليه ال- ال- ال- ال- ال-
ال-
اندام الامن الغذائي
المتاثر من عمليه التغيرات المناخيه
وبالتالي مهم جدا ان يكون هناك عمليه
تمويل همم
المشاريع التي تتعامل على التكيف مع اثار
المناق شكرا لك عبير عطيفه حدثنا من شرم
الشيخ مديره الوحده الاقليميه للاعلام في
برنامج الغذاء العالمي
وفي اول مقابله مع وسيله عربيه قال رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك في مقابله
مع العربيه ان ايران رفضت في مارسيل ماضي
التي فقد نووي والوضع اصبح اكثر صعوبه
بسبب قمع النظام المتظاهرين وافعال ايران
المزعزع للاستقرار وقال صنعك ان العلاقات
بين بريطانيا ومجلس التعاون الخليجي مهمه
وتاريخيه واكد انه يتطلع الى اخذها الى
الامام وتطويرها
[تصفيق]
اكشن كونان
بتاع سناك سناب سناب
عمري
[موسيقى]
وفي اخر التطورات الميدانيه المتعلقه
بالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه قال مفرد العربيه في
العاصمه كياب ان الجيش الاوكراني نفذ اثني
22 غره جويه استهدفت 20 موقعا للقوات
الروسيه منها مخازن الاسلحه والمعدات
العسكريه واكد الجيش الاوكراني ان القوات
الروسيه تقوم بعمليات تعذيب للمواطنين في
خرسون وحولت بعض مناطقها الى شوارع حرب
وجاء هذا في وقت تواصل فيه عمليات القصف
في الشرقي وجنوبي البلاد خصوصا في مدينه
باخمود التي تشهد ضربات بالدبابات
والمدفعيه وفي دنياك حيث تواصل القوات
الروسيه تكثيف هجماتها والدفع بالمرتزقه
والمجندين للخطوط الاولى حيث تضررت العديد
من المباني السكنيه في اوباس في منطقه
الدنيا
القصفه الروسيه
بالتزامني مع تصاعدي القتال بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه شرقي اوكرانيا قال
الرئيس الروسي بلاديمير بوتين ان 50 الفا
من جنود التعبئه الجزئيه تم ارسالهم
للوحدات القتاليه بدوره اعلن وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ان بلاده تسلمت حديثا من
الولايات المتحده واسبانيا والنرويج انظمه
دفاع جويه
كما اكد وزير الدفاع على ان تلك الاسلحه
ستعزز قدرات الجيش الاوكراني الى حد كبير
وستجعل مجال اوكرانيا الجوي اكثر امنا
[تصفيق]
اتاها مع الرئيس الاوكراني موسكو بدار سفن
مدينه او مدنيه في خرسان وقال بان روسيا
تستعد لشنه جماد جديده على البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه في اوكرانيا وبا ان موسكو تتكبر
خسائر كبيره فيها هجماتها المستمره في
اقليم دونياس بشرقي البلاد جاء هذا في وقت
نقلت فيه صحيفه وصفت جورنا الامريكيه عن
مسؤولين امريكاين معلومات عن اجراء
محادثات روسيه امريكيه سريه حيث ان مستشار
الامن القومي
اجرى محادثات غير معلنه مع مساعدين للرئيس
الروسي في محاوله للحد من مخاطر نشوب صراع
او ساعه بشان يؤثر عليها وتاتي هذه
التطورات في وقت سجلته البلاد عجزنا بنسبه
32% في امدادات الكهرباء
[موسيقى]
هذا كان ميدانيا اما على الصعايده
السياسيه فقد افاد احد كبار مستشار رئيس
الاوكرانيه على ان اكياب لم ترفض قد
التفاوض مع موسكو وانها مستعده لاجراء
محادثات مع رئيس روسيا المستقبلي ولكن ليس
الرئيس الروسي الحالي الذي ميرتل وكتب
المستشار الرئيس للرئيس الاوكراني على
حسابي الرسمي عبر تويتر انه اوكرانيا لم
ترفض التفاوض قطط وانا موقفها من التفاوض
معروف ومعلن مشددا على ان روسيا ينبغي
عليها ان تسحب قواتها من اوكرانيا اولا
سمحت رئيسه وزراء فنلندا سنمارين للعربيه
ان السبب الاساسي وراء انضمام بلادها
والسويد ايضا الى حلف الناتو هو الخوف من
وقوعه هجوم روسي كما حصل في اوكرانيا
بحاجه حمايه الماده الخامسه نريد ان نضمن
ان روسيا لن تدخل حدودنا بالرغم من انه لا
تهديدات الان الا اننا نريد ضمان ان روسيا
لن تهددنا وان الدول الاعضاء الاخرى سترسل
الدعوه في حال وقوع اي هجوم علينا لم نكن
لنصل الى هذه المرحله من القلق لولا
الهجوم الروسيه على اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
في استوديو ينضم الينا عبد الجواد الرشد
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد اعتدنا ان اراك
في الميدان غطيت المعارك يعني بالحظات
الحرجه اليوم معنا بالاستديو لنقل الصوره
من هناك الى هنا ما هو الوضع في خصون على
الارض مساء الخير
قوات لا يعرف تعدادها حتى اليوم
مدرعات دبابات
دعم بحري من اسطول دعم من الجو طيارات
المعركه
اا روسيا كانت تتحدث عن 30 كتيبه وبالتالي
عن اي عدد نتحدث العدد من الجانبين لكن
موسكو تتحدث عن ان اعداد القوات
الاوكرانيه
تزيد بكثير يعني اضعاف مضاعفه عن الاعداد
التي اعدها الروس لكن التنوع في القوات
حسب رؤيه الخبراء السياسيين حسب رؤيه
الخبراء العسكريين باننا نلاحظ هناك وجود
قد تكون موجوده قوته قد تكون موجوده هنا
قوات قديره الشيشانيه قوات خاصه روسيه جيش
الروسي قوات دانيتك ولجانس القوات الشعبيه
في تلك المنطقه وبالتالي
الحديث عن قوات النخبه هي موجوده هي
الاقوى على الارض يعني من سير المعارك من
وجود كاميرا العربيه في تلك المناطق هي
النخبه هي الاقوى
التقارير التي تتحدث عن قوه اراكتاد ما
يعرف بالقوات الاوكرانيه وهم المتطوعين
الذين سيشكلون العدد الاكبر على الارض هل
ممكن ان تغير بموازين القوى او بالاعداد
بين الجيشين يعني رؤيه موسكو العسكريه في
معركه ستكون المعركه القاسيه الاكبر وقوات
كيف طبعا في تلك المنطقه ستجعل من الوضع
يعني يحتدم بشكل كبير لكن قوات موسكو كما
يرى البعض هي مقدما على حسب المعركه لكن
حسب القراءات السياسيه الدقيقه والعسكريه
في هذا الموضوع المعركه قد تستمر سنوات
طويله
التي اعلنت عن انتهائها موسكو هناك بعض
التقارير تقول بانها بعض المجندين او بعض
الروسيين ما زالوا يتلقوا اتصالات
للانضمام الى الجيش هل هذا صحيح ام ان هذه
دعايه يعني هذا الكلام غير صحيح
جميع اما مراكز التجنيد وسحب يعني عنصر
الشباب نحو هذه المراكز لتدريبهم ونقلهم
الى الارض على المعركه هي فقط للمتطوعين
من يرغب بدخول ارض المعركه بعقد مراكز
التسجيل وشعب التجنيد هي مفتوحه بالنسبه
له الروسي شاهدنا تقارير تتحدث عن محاوله
العديد القرار همم خارج البلاد او عبر
يعني جرح انفسهم او اختراق اعذار من
الجانب الاوكراني عن ماذا نتحدث ايضا
الاوكراني كما تتحدث التقارير بان البعض
منهم يقوم بشراء بطاقات او شهادات صحيه
تثبيت مرحله الاعاقه من الدرجه الثالثه
حتى لا يلتحاق بالقوات الاوكرانيه يعني
التي قد يتم نقلها الى خرصون في تلك
المناطق
الديموغرافي
منطقه خيرسون لكي تشكل يعني درع امني
بالمرحله المقبله هل هي صحيحه يعني عمليه
التفريغ من السكان تم نقلهم مس بتقدر ما
بين 80 كم الى 120 هذه المسافات تسمح
لموسكو باصطياد كافه الصواريخ الاوكرانيه
بانظمه الدفاع الجوي
بما ان التقارير الغربيه يا خصوصا
الفرنسيه تحدثت باليومين الماضيين على
انها غير قانونيه دوليا هل ممكن ان تذهب
موسكو نحو درب الرادارات التي استفاد منها
الاوكراني باعاذ من الامريكيين هي ملف
ساخن جدا يعني اليوم المحطات الفضائيه
تلعب دور كبير في سير المعركه تقوم بتقديم
التفاصيل حول مكان تواجد القوات حول مكان
توزعها تقدمها بالاضافه الى التجسس على
الاتصالات التحكم وتسير المقاتلات لذلك
انذار موسكو كما يتحدثون هو صحيح بالكامل
وقد تقوم باستهداف المحطات او تعطيل بعض
عملها اذا وضعت في موقف خارج خاصه
مقبل على مرحله
هل ممكن ان نتحدث عن قلب موازين الدفاع عن
الارض خصوصا ان كل التقرير سابقه تتحدث عن
تفوق المدفعيه الروسيه على الغربيه
الروسيه موجوده في مكانها الدعم الغربي
لكيف موجود بشكل كبير هناك يعني ملاحظه
كبيره موجوده بان يعني الجهتين موسكو وكيف
تعدانا العداء لكن ليال الرابح في هذه
المعركه خاسر ايضا شكرا لك عبد الجواد
الرشد على وجودك معنا وسنعود معك عند
عودتك الى الميدان
[موسيقى]
بيتزا سلاح بالمجان ينتظره الاوكرانيون
لكسب الحرب ضد روسيا هذا السلاح ليس من
صناعه الغرب بل من صناعه الصوفيه بل من
طبيعه اوكرانيا
فتره انتقاليه للطقس ينتظرها الاوكرانيون
بفارغ الصبر حيث ستعقد التحركات العسكريه
في ساحه القتال المخاوف تتزايد من الجو
جانب الروسي من الطين الخريف الذي سيكون
سببا في عرقله مسار العمليات العسكريه في
شرقي وجنوبي اوكرانيا
ذوبان الثلوج فوفقا مراقبين القوات
الروسيه ستتكبت خسائر كبيره تزامنا مع
موسم ما يعرف به راسبه وهي الفتره الراقبه
الموحله التي يتسببها ذوبان الثلوج في
الربيع والامطار الغزيره في فصل الخريف
حيث ستصبح مشاهدينا عمليه نقل الجنود
الروس والعتاد الحربي الروسي من مدرعات
ودبابات ونقلات جنود فوق الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
المتجمده صعبه جدا مما يجعلها عرضا للصيد
بانظمه الدفاع المضاده للدروع وابرزها
صواريخ جافيلد وهنا الجيش الاوكراني سيكون
قادرا على المضيق قدما في دومباز واستعاده
خرسون ومواصله الدفع بزخم في الجنوب
والشمال الشرقي قبل بدء الفتره الموحله
التي ستوقف تقدم القوات الروسيه وفق صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه فتره راسبوتيتا
ستجلب معها ظروفا صعبه للجيش الروسي وفرصا
للجيش الاكرانيا الذي سيتمكن من استهداف
خزانات الوقود وقوافل الامدادات الروسيه
ووضع الجنود الروس في مواجهه الدراجات
الحراره المنخفضه التي قد تميتهم تجمدا
كما ستساهم في مضاعفات تحركات الجيش الاوك
الذي لا يستعمل كثيرا الاسلحه الثقيله بل
اسلحه تكنولوجيه جديده على عكس روسيا التي
ستضطر الى التوقف بسبب استخدامها الدبابات
والمدرعات والمدفعيه الثقيله فما اقتراب
هذا الموسم ستصبح الحرب البريه اكثر صعوبه
وستصبح معها مهام اعاده امداد الخطوط
الاماميه اكثر صعوبه كما ستواجه المدفعيه
صعوبه في التحرك لاستخدام اطلاق النار
والهرب مما سيجعل استخدام المدفعيه اكثر
خطوره لكلال الشريف
[موسيقى]
جيش ورقتك الاوكراني استخفت به موسكو في
قلب الطاوله على الجيش الروسي منذ بدايه
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه شكلت كتائب او العاديين جزء
كبير من دفاعك عن اراضيها الكتائب التي
تضم تطوعين مدنيين وبعد تحقيقها مكاسب
كبيره في العاصمه كاف تتجه نحو اقليم
خرسان لتحرير المنطقه التي يمكن ان تشهد
اكبر واشهر الصدام منذ بدايه الحرب قوات
جيش الراكتا كانت السلطات الاوكرانيه قد
بدات تدريبها قبل بدايه الحرب حيث قدر عدد
هؤلاء وقتها
ب12,000 شخص واستمر تطوع المدنيين في
القتال بشكل اكبر بعد الحرب حيث ساهموا في
تحقيق انتصارات كبيره في الشرقيه البلاد
حيث شراء تحرير خارقوز بالكامل واجزاء
اخرى من الدباس حسب صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
الامريكي
[موسيقى]
التاسعه المستمره وفيها بعد قليل
دعوات المانيه لل الاتحاد الاوروبي بفرض
عقوبات ضد الحرس الثوري الايراني
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى ملف انتخابات
التجديد النصفي في الولايات المتحده والتي
اقتحامها مالك توتير الجديد الى ماسك
مطالبا بتقاسم السلطه بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين
[موسيقى]
اوصى رجل الاعمال الامريكيه الى ماسك
بتصويت للجمهوريين بانتخابات التجديد
النصفي الامريكيه المرتقبه وقال ماسك ان
تقاسم السلطه بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين يمنع تواغل اي من الحزبين
في الحكم مضيفا انه يفضل ان يسيطر
الجمهوريين على الكونجرس لان الرئيس
الحالي في البيت الابيض هو تشوبايدن
الديمقراطي لذلك يجب ان تكون سلطه
الكونجرس بيد الحزب الجمهوريه
من واشنطن مراسله العربيه ناديه البلبيسي
ناديه سابدا من ما ذكرناه دخول ماسك على
خط الانتخابات كيف قراه الديمقراطيون
والجمهوريون
اه طبعا البيت الابيض سئل عن التداخل الى
الماسك في السابق وطبعا قلعه المتحدثه
باسم بانه ربما ليس في مكان
ان يتحدث عن الانتخابات الامريكيه التي في
الاساس هناك الكثير من السجلات وكما
تعرفين خصوصا في وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
عن شرعيه الانتخابات ونظريات المؤامره
والى اخره وبالتالي لا يرغب البيت الابيض
بشخصيه مثل ماسك ان يتحدث عن الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الانتخابات النصفيه او حتى
الانتخابات الرئاسيه او ان يكون شخص معين
يعني ان يدعمه بالتالي يترك الخيار للناخ
الامريكي بالدرجه الاولى همم ناديه تحركات
الساعات الاخيره من قبل يعني الرؤساء بهذه
الانتخابات والعنوان الاساسي اقتصادي كيف
هي الصوره
بالفعل الالوان الاقتصادي الاساسي هو
اقتصادي تضخم هذا بالنسبه للناخب الامريكي
لكن بالنسبه للبيت الابيض وبالنسبه لا
الديمقراطين يحاولون في اللحظات الاخيره
ان يحشدوا معيديهم والذين لم يقرروا حتى
الان وبالنهايه هذه الانتخابات سيقررها
اولئك الذين سيذهبون الى صناديق الاقتراع
اريد ان اذكر بان هناك 41 مليون امريكي
صوتوا في انتخابات مبكره وبالتالي وجود
الرئيس كما رايته في ولايه بنسلفانيا
الحاسمه في عطله نهايه الاسبوع ووجود
الرئيس
كما ذكر فيها الاقتصاد هو العنوان
ناديه المتارجحون او ما يعرف بجمهوره
بايدون وديمقراطيه ترامب كيف يمكن ان يحسم
تصويطهم بالساعات المقبله
هذا يعتمد على المرشح وعلى الولايه يعني
نحن نتحدث عن بعض الولايات التي ستحسم هذا
السباق على الاقل في مجلس الشيوخ في مجلس
النواب تقريبا يمكن ان نقول بان محسومه
لان الجمهوريين بحاجه الى خمس مقاعد فقط
والتوقعات الان هل سيحصلون عما يسمى
بالموجه الحمراء اي سيفتحون المجلس
سيحصلون على 28 مقعد ام لا هذا هو السؤال
لكن بشكل يفوزون بمجلس النواب مجلس الشيوخ
هناك حسب المرشح يعني هناك مرشحين في مثلا
في ولايه مرشح مدعوم من قبل
ديمقراطي وهو معروف بانه كان لديه مشاكل
صحيه وبالتالي انا المرشحين غير مؤهلين
وبالتالي البعض قد يصوت للمرشحه حسبته حسب
ما وعد في اللحظات الاخيره وهذا ينطبق على
ولايه مثل جورجيا
المرشحان هم همم من اصولهم افريقيا واحد
منهم ايضا من قبل ترامب وبالتالي الذين
سيصوتون او سمونا هذه الانتخابات هم الذين
سيذهبون الى صناديق الاقتراع باستطاعه
الحزب الجموري والحزب الديمقراطي ان
يدفعان الناخبين لكن بالنهايه من سيذهب
ومن سيصوت هو المنتخب شكرا لك ناديه
البلبيسي مراسله العربيه حدثنا من واشنطن
يلعب الناخبون المتارجحون او الحاسونه
غالبا دورا مهما في تحديد من سيفوز في تلك
الانتخابات الامريكيه من هم الناخبون
المتارجحون وكيف يصوتوا اولا يفضلون لقب
الوسطيين ولديهم بعض النفور من كلا
الحسبين السياسيين الرئيسيين هناك
افتراضين حول او افتراضيين حول
واشنطس الاول هو انه في الاساس من
الوسطيين ولهم وجهات نظر متقاربه ويصوتون
لمرشحين اقرب الى الوسط والثاني هو ان
هؤلاء الناخبين بدلا من ارتباطهم بواقف اي
من الحسبين يقومون بتحليل موضوع لظروف في
البلاد ثم الادلاء باصواتهم وفقا لذلك لا
سيما الانفصال عن الحزب الذي تم التصويت
له سابقا اذا كان الاقتصاد
ان يخيبون المترشحون غالبا لا يتمتعون
وقف ليبراليه او محافظه في جميع المجالات
ويفضلون ان يتم التعريف بهم على انهم
معتدلون ولديهم نفس المسافه من الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهور طبعا لكن في ذات
الوقت هناك فئه اخرى لديها مزيج من
المواقف الليبراليه والمواقف المحافظه
وعلى اساسه يقوم افراد هذه الفئه باختيار
مرشحهم المفضل البعض الاخر يحلل في مركز
معظم القضايا الرئيسيه لسياسه الداخليه
والخارجيه للنواب السابقين وعلى اساسهم
التصويت وايضا هنا فئه وتعتبر صغيره من
الوسطيين او المتارجحين ليس لديهم مواقف
سياسيه وجل اعتمادها هؤلاء على الاقتصاد
والقضايا القانونيه والاجتماعيه والقوانين
الاجتماعيه والى حد ما قضايا المراه
الامريكيه وهناك نقطه اخيره على هؤلاء
المتارجحين فهم لا يحبون ان يروا نفس
الحزب في البيت الابيض لاكثر من فترتين
لذلك يسعى اولى الناخبون المتارجحون لمنع
اي من الحزبين من الفوز باكثر من ولايتين
ما قد يقلل من حظوط الديمقراطيين هذه
المره بهذه الانتخابات
بعد عامين من بدء ولايه الرئيس الامريكي
التي تدوم لاربع سنوات يتوجه الناخبون
الامريكيون الى صناديق الاقتراع في
الثلاثاء الثاني من نوفمبر للتصويت فيما
يعرف بانتخابات التجديد النصفي
تشمل اعاده انتخاب مجلس النواب بكافه
اعضائه 435 لفتره عامين وثلث اعضاء مجلس
الشيوخ اي 35 مقعدا من اصل 100 مقعد
بالاضافه الى 36 من حكام الولايات الخمسين
[موسيقى]
تحدد هذه الانتخابات من سيحكم سيطرته على
مجلسي الشيوخ والنواب حاليا يسيطر
الديمقراطيون على المجلسين وان باغلبيه
بسيطه وهو ما يمنح اريحيه للرئيس
الديمقراطي جو بيد بتطبيق سياساته من دون
عرقله من الكونغرس
لكن ماذا لو انقلب لوضع عمليا لا يحتاج
الجمهوريون للكثير لقلب الطاوله ففي مجلس
النواب لديهم حاليا واثنى عشر مقعدنا
ويحتاجون فقط لسته مقاعد اضافيه للحصول
على الاغلبيه في المجلس اما في مجلس
الشيوخ فلديهم نصف عدد المقاعد وبالتالي
يحتاجون لمقعد اضافي واحد فقط
[موسيقى]
اذا فاز الجمهوريون بالاغلبيه في المجلسين
سيمضي الرئيس بقيه فترته الرئاسيه كبطه
عرجه غير قادر على الحركه وهو الذي يعاني
بالفعل من تدن غير مسبوق في نسبه شعبيته
التي تراجعت لاقل من 40 في المئه
يركز الجمهوريون بالدرجه الاولى على قضايا
اقتصاديه مثل التضخم ويلقون الضوء على ما
يصفونه باخفاقات سياسه اداره بيضا
الاقتصاديه التي زادت التضخم وادت لرفع
اسعار الوقود
الديمقراطيون يتشاركون مع الحزب الجمهوري
في بعض القضايا الاقتصاديه بالاضافه
لملفات جدليه كقرار المحكمه العليا تقييد
حق الاجهاض
من المعتاد ان يخسر الحزب الحاكم مقاعده
في اول انتخابات تجديد النصفيه كون الناخب
لا يفضل التصويت بالكونجرس للحزب الحاكم
المتواجد داخل البيت الابيض خوفا من تركز
السلطه بيد حزب واحد الا ان تلك القاعده
كسرت مرتين فقط الاولى بفوز الحزب
الجمهوري في عهد ترامب والثانيه كانت في
عهد اوباما
[موسيقى]
شيران لا حل امام النظام الا القمع
وبوحشيه للتعامل مع الاحتجاجات التي شكل
مقتل مهسا اميني شراره انطلاقتها قتل وخطف
وتهديدات بالاعدام سينما المحتاجين وقطع
الانترنت وحظر خروج المدنيين كل ذلك لم
ينفع في مواجهه المحتاجين حتى الان
السادسه جامعيون حذروا في بيان من رفع
وتيره القمع والقسوه بحق الطلبه فيما كشفت
منظمه هناك لحقوق الانسان عن مقتل هنداوي
لحقوق الانسان عفوا عن مقتل لا يقل عن 61
مواطنا كرديا وجرح واعتقال اكثر من خمسه
الاف شخص حتى الان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اعلنت الحكومه الالمانيه
الحرس الثوري الايراني على لائحه عقوبات
جديده هذا وكانت المانيا دول اخرى في
الاتحاد قد خطط لتوسيع العقوبات ضد النظام
الايراني يجرا اقمع المظاهرات والعنف
المستخدم ضد المتظاهرين الايرانيين
تتابعونا ولكن بعد قليل
[موسيقى]
على خطى جارتها تويتر مته بصدد تسريح عدد
غير مسبوق من موظفها
[موسيقى]
حلقه صغيره وضيقه شكلها الى ماسك لاداره
منصته الزرقاء تويتر والحلقه تضم اصدقاء
ومستثمرون ومحامون مقربون لماسك سيكونون
ضمن الفريق الجديد الذي سيدير شركه تويتر
في المرحله المقبله والهدف الاستمراريه
وزياده الارادات حيث سيضم المجلس الجديد
الذي يساعد ماسك في اجراءات تقييم الشركه
وتنزيل رؤيته ومشاريعه محاميه الشخصيه
ومستثمرين من اصدقائه ومدير تنفيذه سابق
في تويتر ترك الشركه قبل سنوات الاختيار
الاول كان على الشريك القديم
والمستثمر في مجال التكنولوجيا جيسون الذي
طرح العديد من الافكار حول مستقبل الشركه
وعين في منصب مهندس برمجيات داخل الشركه
اما جارد الذي يعاد اقرب مستشاري الى مصر
يدير ثروته الشخصيه كرئيس لمكتب عائلته
منذ العام 2016 وكان من المساهمين
الرئيسيين في اعداد تمويل صفقه شراء تويتر
فسيكون احد واضعي خطط واستراتيجيات عمل
تويتر في المرحله المقبله المحامي اليكس
بيرو فلقد تحول من الممثل القانوني له
ماسك الى المسؤول عن الفرق القانونيه
والعلاقات الحكوميه والسياسيه والتسويق في
تويتر وديفيد ثانكس الذي عمل مع ماسك منذ
ان كان لاثنان جزءا من فريق شركه بايبال
قبل 20 سنه فسيتولى منصب مهندس برامج
الموظفين اما القيادي سيرام كريشنا عن
اعلن انه سيساعد مع ماسك في اداره المنصه
مؤقتا واشارت واشنطن بوصله لان مهامه في
تويتر غير واضحه لكنه يبقى الوحيد في فريق
مارس الذي سبق له العمل في هذه الشركه
[موسيقى]
ايضا بموضوع تويتر
تماما كما سيتم ايقاف كما تم ايقاف حساب
الممثله الكوميديه كافه
ههه
ما عدا الملياردير الامريكي الى الماس
كوميديا كما ظنه بعض المستخدمين فخلفت تلك
الضحكات وجه صارم ينفذ سياسته المرجوه بلا
ان يتوانى قيد انمل عن تحقيق الهدف
قبل ايام اي منذ استحواذه رسميا على
العصفور الازرق غرد قائلا الكوميديا على
تويتر اصبحت قانونيه منشور لقاء اعجاب من
قبل كثيرين على خلاف مساله توفيق الحسابات
ووضع العلامه الزرقاء مقابل الثمانيه
دولارات لانها لم تنال استحسان الاغلبيه
وامام ذاك القرار شهد تويتر موجه من
الانتقادات والدعابات كان يحول مشاهير او
شخصيه معروف اسم العرض الى الى الماسك لكن
ماسك كان لهم بالمرصاد وانها امرهم بحضن
الحساب تماما كما جرى مع الممثله
الكوميديه كافي جريفن التي يتابعها نحو
مليون شخص غيرت اسمها والصوره الشخصيه
ليظهر الحساب خارجيا وكانه لمسك لك لكن رد
مالك العصفور الازرق لم يلبث الا قليلا
حتى اغلق حسابها
وتعادته يوم ماسك سياسته عبر سيل تغريدات
بداها قائلا ان المنصه لن تتهاون في تعليق
اي حساب عند انتحاله هويه بلا ان يحدد
صاحب الحساب انها مجرد محاكاه ساخره
وتابع ان التحقيقات ستاخذ مجراها وتتسع بل
انه لن يكون هناك تحذير واردف ان اي تغيير
في الجسم سيفقد الحساب مؤقتا علامته
الزرقاء حتى تعود المنصه التحقق منها
واضمن سياسه تويتر لا يجوز انتحال شخصيه
افراد او مجموعات او مؤسسات لتظليل
الاخرين او اربياكهم او حتى خداعهم لكن
المستخدمين يبدو انه معترضوا على مسالتي
الدولارات والمحاكاه الساخره فالاولى لا
داعي لدفعها اما الثانيه فتدخل بالنسبه
اليهم حيز حريه التعبير
اسراء الصغير العربيه
في خطوه غير مسبوقه وعلى خطه جارتها تويتر
تدرس شركه متى خطه تعتزم فيها تسريح واسع
نطاق للموظفين هذا الاسبوع ونقلت صحيفه عن
اشخاص مطلعين على الامر بان موجه
التسريحات الجديده بشركه ميتا الملكه
لمنصات فيسبوك وواتساب وانستغرام قد تكون
الاكبر في الوظائف التقنيه بعد النمو
السريع للصناعه خلال الوباء ومن المتوقع
ان تؤثر عمليات تسريحه العادات من
الموظفين
من بيروت ينضم الينا عمر قصقص الصحافي
والخبير في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي عمر
سابدا من خبر التسريح الذي ذكرناه عن مته
هناك تقرير لبلومبرج اليوم يتحدث عن ان
اداره تويتر عاده وتواصلت مع عادت من
الموظفين بعد ما اكتشفت انه تم تسريحهم
بالغلط وان وظائفهم لا يمكن ان تستبدل
بهذه السرعه ما الذي يحصل في
نعم
في تقريبا حوالي 12,000 شخص هيخرج من
الشركه بعد ما همم تملك الشركه حوالي
87.000 موظف لكل انحاء العالم و خسره خلال
هذا العام نسطر اليوم دولار لان ظهر يا
ليال همم تيك توك راح يخلي شركه وراح يخلي
الموظفين باي شركه لان التيك توك طالع
نسول وباء الشركات همم وفي تقريبا يعني
خلال هذا العام 87% من قيمه الى تويتر همم
نزلت لان توقعات همم الى ماسك بخصوص المان
بتاع فيروس
في كثير كثير
ممكن على يعني استقبال العالم العالم
على التوقعات همم
اكثر من هيك في تقارير بتقول انه لا في
ناس فاتت اكثر
في تقرير بتقوله هيدا اللي مقتنع فيها
شركه تويتر انه الشركات سبقه العالم
بالانفسنك يعني في في قاعده بقوله فيها
وين في ناس اعمل شركه همم هايدث الماده
فيرسر بالعكس عامله شركه قبل ما يجوا
الناس يعني هلا اذا بدنا ننزل انا واياك
على على الطريق بس منكسر هيك شوي عشر
دقائق وبنسال الناس شو يعني ما تفسر بقول
لك ما بنعرف في سقفت الماتفرس بعد ما وصلت
لكل الناس همم وانا كثير بيجيني عرض عندكم
كومنتات طيب شو يعني في لازم العالم تعرف
شو هو فارس بعدين الشركات بتحط تمارا
اثنين مليار انا هذا الامر منه سهل يعني
جلابه همم
نحن يعني للمره الاولى رئيس
مواقع تواصل الاجتماعي هو من يدير يعني هو
من يقوم همم
بلوك ما بعرف بالعربي ليه حسابات الناس
كاننا نتحدث عن ادمن للكوكب كله
همم المشكله بقى لهم ما بقالهم ماسك انه
مفكر تويتر مثل تسلا انه انا بجيب سياره
باختراعها وممشيها بالسوق تويتر غير لهم
ماسك هلا دشرت 3700 موظف وبرجعوا على شركه
تويتر بيدقوا لهم قال لهم ماسك بقلك بدي
ادفع العالم 8$ يعني
باخر التاريخ لان خاف ما حدا افترضنا يعمل
باسم فيكم يدفعك من الدولار باسم شرقي
جمهوريه ما عنده تويتر
يعني سالك قاعد وحده لهم ماسك عم يكتب
تاريخ اسود على موقع ازرق
تويتر رايحه الفشل مع انه انا كنت اتوقع
بذكاء لهم ماسك انه وقلت على الهواء انه
انه تنجح الشركه بس القرارات ياخذها بها
السرعه ويرجع يتراجع عن كل قرار ويقوم
عليه العالم انت معك خبر انه ثلاثه ارباع
الشركات
اللي قطعت التويتر اطلع افضح اسماءها يعني
الشركه حره على فيسبوك
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
ارتكبت الميليشيات الحوثيه شراء ام جوسيما
بحق المدنيين في تعزيه ما في الاحياء
الغربيه القريبه من خطوط تماثل حرب حيث
اقدمت الميليشيات على تدمير منازل
المواطنين بالقصف المدفعي في عده احياء
بين الركام حتى الصوت للحج رعبا لم يشهدوا
ساكلون من قبله الى الغرب من تعز تحديدا
حيث المطار القديم تخبرك المشاهده عن حجم
القذف الحوثي الذي استهدف المدنيين في
منازلهم بل وجعل اكثر من 120 منزلا في
احياء تعز الغربيه
ولا نجران عمل اي شيء
كله صعب عندنا
والمدارس والكل
ما نقدرش نتحرك ولا نقدر نفعل اي شيء
كما يقولون في الحياه بالنسبه لهم في الحي
هذا وان بدات محفوفه بالمخاطر اهون من
المبيت لليله واحده في المخيمات
من جرائم بشكل يومي
استهداف للطفوله
استهداف النساء
نستنكر صمت الامم المتحده وتعاونها
وتعاونها معامل الشيخ الحوثي الاجراميه
شمال تعز فهناك اكثر من 500 اسره يمنيه في
الاحياء
الغربيهم يوميا برصاص وقناصه الميليشيات
بحاله رعب اذا تعيش عشرات الاسر اليمنيه
في حي المطار القديم هذا غربي مدينه تعز
نتيجه القصف والقنص العشوائي التي
تشبهنيشات الحوثيه عليهم ليلا نهار خلف
هذا الحاجز لا احد يستطيع الظهور خوفا من
السيدافه بطلاقه القناص هل سعيد لقناتي
العربيه والحدث من حي المطار القديم
الغربي مدينه تعز
الى مصر وبعد اربع جلسات بدات في سبتمبر
الماضي اصدرت محكمه جنايات الزقازيق حكما
باعدام الطالب اسلام محمد فتحي بعد ادانته
بقتل زميلته في الجامعه الطالبه سلمى بهجت
مع سبق الاصرار والترصد تامر نصره
والتفاصيل
بقتل زميلته في الجامعه الطالبه سلمى بهجت
مع سبق الاصرار والترصد في جريمه ارتكبت
على مرمى حجر من هذه المحكمه
وسط اجراءات امنيه مشدده في محيطها ورضا
من قبل اهالي الضحيه عن الحكم رغم علمهم
بنيه المدان نقد الحكم طبعا هم هم في طاعن
طبعا دي اجراءات قانونيه لازم تمشي وضد
دستور بتاعنا يقدمه الطعن بتاعها وده عادي
لان ديت لازم تجرارات قانونيه في الدستور
المصري عايزه سلمى ان شاء الله بعد بامر
الله بعد ما يتنفس حكم الاعدام على
الاسلام والد المحكوم عليه بالاعدام حاول
بعد رفع الجلسه رؤيه ابنيه لطمئنته لناحيه
الخطوات القادمه وتقدمه بنقد الحكم خلال
60 يوما من تاريخه ده واحد مريض نفسي ولهم
ملف في الصحه النفسيه ازاي ياخذ اعدام
مفيش فرع
الحكم صدر بعد اربع جلسات فقط بدات في
سبتمبر الماضي قبل ان يستقر في عقيده
المحكمه ان المتهم لا يعاني من مرض النفسي
وانه مسؤول عن افعاله طبقا للتقرير الطبي
تامر نصره العربيه الزقازيق
عام 20 50
الاخضر الامير محمد بن سلمان يؤكد على
مساعد السعوديه للوصول الى الحياد الصفري
في عام 2050
ايران
الاتفاق النووي مع ايران باتا معقدا
بقمعها للمحتاجين